А ви знали, що в Німеччині в адресі спочатку пишуть вулицю, а потім номер будинку?
А індекс стоїть перед містом.
Подивіться-но на дверні дзвінки: жодних номерів!
Натомість наліпки з прізвищами мешканців.
Дивно для країни, де так стежать за захистом особистих даних.
Як би там не було, сьогодні ми йдемо до німців у гості.
Німецькі будинки бувають різного стилю й розміру.
А ще у них досить логічні назви.
Крайній будинок в ряду так і називається - "будинок в кінці ряду" або "Reihenendhaus".
Будинок на одну сім'ю називається односімейним будинком - Einfamilienhaus.
Великі багатоквартирні будинки називають "багатосімейними" - Mehrfamilienhäuser.
Таких будинків у Німеччині найбільше.
Німці зазвичай точно знають метраж своєї житлоплощі.
У середньому це трохи більше 90 квадратних метрів - для двох осіб.
П'ять мільйонів німців живуть у "WG" - це щось на зразок комуналки.
І тільки 0,5% домогосподарств об'єднують три або більше поколінь під одним дахом.
Квартплату без урахування комунальних послуг німці називають "холодною", а з урахуванням комуналки - "теплою".
Німеччина - країна орендарів. Менше половини населення володіє нерухомістю, а в деяких великих містах таких усього чверть.
Почасти це має історичні причини.
Під час війни було зруйновано багато приватного житла, тому як швидке рішення проблеми будували багатоквартирні будинки під оренду.
У колишній НДР люди майже не мали можливості купувати нерухомість, тоді як державне житло субсидіювалося.
У наші дні дехто віддає перевагу орендованому житлу через можливість бути мобільним.
Адже німці переїжджають у середньому 6 разів у житті.
Але для більшості головна причина не купувати своє житло - постійне зростання цін на нерухомість і необхідний для цього стартовий капітал.
Утім, винаймати житло - це зовсім не дешева альтернатива.
У Мюнхені орендарі платять понад 17 євро за квадратний метр.
Берлін намагається стримувати ціни за допомогою суперечливої заборони на зростання квартплати протягом п'яти років.
Деякі німці виявляють винахідливість і відмовляються від традиційного житла на користь будинків- човнів,
автобудинків, комунальних житлових проєктів і будиночків типу Tiny House.
Tiny House - це невеликий будиночок, зазвичай з дерева, площею від 10 до 20 квадратних метрів,
на колесах, наприклад, на базі автомобільного причепа.
Це особливий рух, який зародився в Каліфорнії близько 15 років тому.
- І як він докотився до Німеччини?
- У Німеччині завжди були популярні дачі, схожі на Tiny House.
Німці, як і голландці, обожнюють кемпінги та автотуризм. Вони люблять такі невеликі простори.
- Які переваги дає такий будинок?
- Що менше житлоплощі, тим менше речей ми можемо купити.
Якби всі жили в дерев'яних будинках, не було б таких катастрофічних проблем з викидами СО2.
І якщо ми хочемо жити не в безликих багатоповерхівках, а в менших будинках, то й наші взаємини у соціумі поліпшаться.
Однак повернімося в сьогодення. Ось мій особистий рейтинг речей, які роблять будинок по-справжньому німецьким.
Домашні капці.
Вода в пляшках - газована, звичайно.
Дивні міні-виделки для торта.
Якщо сам торт не маленький, то навіщо такі виделки?
Жалюзі, які взагалі не пропускають сонячне світло.
Складний дерев'яний метр в стилі ретро.
Відсіки під склад у підвалах.
Улюблений балкон - найпопулярніша частина квартири.
Дві ковдри на ліжку - дуже зручно. І величезні, м'які, безглузді квадратні подушки.
Новоприбулим у Німеччині новосілля часто підносить сюрпризи.
По-перше, не чекайте, що будинок або квартира будуть мебльовані, навіть якщо ви знімаєте житло.
Проте найнеприємніший сюрприз чекає на кухні.
Так, у Німеччині цілком звична справа - забирати із собою при переїзді всю кухню: столи і полиці, плиту, раковину... все!
Одна приємна особливість місцевого переїзду - його колективний дух.
Можете спокійно просити усіх своїх друзів допомогти вам.
Єдина плата за це - пиво, піца і усвідомлення того, що ви віддячите їм тим же.
Німеччина, звісно, не була б Німеччиною без довгого переліку правил.
Дрібним шрифтом у договорі оренди може бути прописаний навіть точний рівень шуму, який вам дозволено створювати.
Або як часто ви повинні провітрювати квартиру, а також вимога перефарбувати всі кімнати в "нейтральний" колір, виїжджаючи.
Хочете додати щось про життя в Німеччині? Пишіть у коментарях!
Дякую, що зайшли!